[Musique]
il ya quand même des vaccins qui donne
la sclérose en plaques ou qui rendent
autistes alors pour l'autisme soyons
très clairs il y à une étude de 1998 qui
disait qu'il y avait un lien entre le
vaccin rer et l'autisme depuis toutes
les études menées montrent que c'est
faux et la fameuse étude de 1998 ça a
été prouvé que non seulement elle était
bidon mais en plus elles étaient
malhonnêtes
d'ailleurs la majorité des gens qui
l'avaient mené depuis ils se sont
rétractés alors pour la sclérose en
plaques
c'est un peu différent dans les années
90 quand on a commencé à beaucoup
vacciner contre l'hépatite b
des gens qui ont développé une sclérose
en plaques ont accusé les vaccins il ya
plein d'études qui ont été menées sur ce
sujet
ce qu'il en est ressorti c'est que la
maladie s'est déclarée chez des
adolescents ou des jeunes adultes c'est
à dire à l'âge où elle se déclare
habituellement et que les gens vaccinés
nous pas plus de risque de développer
une sclérose en plaques
je les non vaccinés par contre les non
vaccinés ils ont plus de risque de
choper une hépatite b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]